[Musique]
ça semblait de plus en plus populaires
parce que les gens commencent à avoir
une plus grande conscience
environnementale et de consommation
locale
vous permettez vraiment de réduire
vraiment votre impact vous vous
permettez de réduire vos déchets réjean
simard pense que c'est mal trope le vrac
est ce que le fait d'offrir des aliments
dans un format nouveaux vont nous mettre
plus à risque d'être malade l'achat
d'aliments en vrac est de plus en plus
populaire les surfaces agrandissent
l'offre se diversifie
alors que 90 % des canadiens veulent
réduire leurs emballages alimentaires et
qu'ils viennent avec leurs contenants
mais sinon ça se passe avec des
cuillères ou des spatules
c'est pas un remplissage qui est 100%
sans degor intéressant du point de vue
environnemental
mais le phénomène amène aussi son lot de
questionnements concernant la salubrité
des aliments des gens souvent parce que
c'est mal propre le vrac que lé quai
tout se mélange à ensemble que la
qualité des produits et paula mais en
fait c'est complètement faux c'est
vraiment notre responsabilité à nous les
épiciers de s'assurer que les aliments
soient de qualité de 1 mais aussi de
d'éduquer les gens et de les amener à
bien se servir en vrac citons de
respecteur y en a pas de problème selon
le ministère de l'agriculture des
pêcheries et de l'alimentation du québec
les épiciers sont en effet responsables
de la salubrité des aliments
la loi sur les produits alimentaires
encadre la pratique en plus d'informer
les clients
il faut parfois les suivre pas à pas et
beaucoup de règles à suivre
on sait pas où sont les outils quels
sont les outils
il ya tellement de produits qui on sait
pas par où commencer non plus donc c'est
pour ça qu'on est là pour éduquer les
clients
règle numéro 1 la propreté de nos
contenus ce soir que la responsabilité
du client c'est d'apporter des
contenants propre s'il veut avoir des
produits qui restent frites dans ses
comptes en mai pour l'épicier c'est à
nous de leur offrir des produits qui ont
été bien traitées biens entreposés qui
sont dans des contenants propres qui ont
eu la rotation 'achat' et rehaussé
c'est une responsabilité qui est donc
partagée règle numéro 2 un instrument
pour chaque aliment l'épicier décide de
la méthode
ici il n'ya aucun ustensiles devant les
bacs sûrement une telle ou une pince pas
reproduit donc et mettons qu'on voudrait
du cnoa ok on prendra l'acheter à
l'appel cette flèche mais mon choix est
exactement
donc mettons on prend la quantité qu'on
a besoin pour vous y tromper le pauvre
comme ça ensuite on va disposer de
l'appel nous on a un bac appel
sall a fait donc un vol mettre dedans
avec l'entonnoir aussi donc si vous
preniez exemple des amendes ou chocolat
ça cool trop vite que vous ramassez avec
50 de leurs demandes au chocolat on est
responsable de localités ont fait pas
les remettre dans le pool jamais donc au
même titre qu'ils ont peut pas faire un
jeu trop de farine dans mon contenant
leurs maîtres dans l'autre ça c'est non
donc du mamac c'est dans le contenant
c'est à vous prendre
nous rencontrons la microbiologiste
evelyne guévremont chercheuse en
salubrité des aliments
vous direz qu'en ce moment il n'y a
aucune évidence scientifique qui nous
permet de croire qu'on serait plus à
risque de tomber malade en consommant
des aliments qu'on aurait acheté en
aubrac comparativement des aliments
qu'on aurait acheté dans un emballage
fourni par la compagnie donc il n'y a
pas de raison de s'alarmer qu'on va être
plus malades
la seule chose c'est qu'il faut
s'assurer de bien manipuler ces aliments
n'a et de respecter les bonnes pratiques
ont fait en droit tient lavabo jelly
arrive souvent ce genre de choses oui
c'est pour ça qu'on aime être présent
quand même du remplissage
c'est pour ça aussi qu'on a les bacs
pour recueillir les dégâts des yenni le
lavabo pour pouvoir nettoyer les
contenants des clients ou les bouteilles
on leur donne des balises plus strict
pour s'assurer qu'ils aiment le moins de
contamination croisée possible
on parle souvent de la contamination
croisée des aliments frais sont par
nature plus contaminés que des aliments
plus sec
donc si on met en contact des aliments
secs avec des aliments frais on pourrait
à ce moment-là comptait mener nos
aliments c
pour limiter davantage la contamination
croisée l'épicier peut décider de
remplir pour voulait beaucoup comme pour
le beurre de noix pourquoi pas
sévèrement qu'elles sont génique
manipulation et un bandeau noir foot
reçoit bien brasser puis leur faut
prendre un culte ils font fuir une façon
de faire pour ne pas contaminer le reste
ou encore la mayonnaise qui plus
fragiles à la contamination
donc on veut avoir un contrôle parfait
son niveau du gène de l'outil avec
lequel il va être servi de la surface
sur laquelle va être servi d'autres font
même tout le remplissage pour vous comme
ici chez beaucoup beaucoup
c'est le principe de la consigne voilà
comme une crainte que la consigne ne se
soit pas propre mais dans le fond une
bouteille de bière elle va être tourné
jusqu'à six fois puis quand tu vas au
restaurant mais tu vas pas dire abel la
personne avant moi la manger dans cette
assiette une fois que c'est passé dans
la vaisselle fixe et assainit le vocal
il ressort il est propre
règle numéro de poids différentes
sections dans l'épicerie c'est important
que les activités reliées la
manipulation des aliments soient séparés
tant qu'ayant un endroit dédié au lavage
des aliments qui est un endroit dédié à
l'entreposage des éléments ont réduit le
risque de façon générale dans
l'établissement
un produit qui est très bas pas être
rempli de manière qu'un produit qui
siècle peut-être pas sur les mêmes zones
non plus avec les mêmes outils
on va avoir le lait le yogourt points
dans la même section le ménager dans une
section les jeunes dans une section les
fruits séchés ensemble les noix ensemble
c'est pour faciliter finalement le
voyage dans la boutique si vous voulez
la dernière règle poser des questions
pour s'assurer des bonnes pratiques en
place dans l'établissement et pour
établir la confiance en son épicier puis
commencer tranquillement pour mieux
réussir
selon carol ann de commencer un pot à la
fois par un système que ça c'est vrai
que ça peut être frustrant de vouloir
tout faire en même temps
donc tu as les petits passent pas pour
traverser à son propre rythme la
transition vers le zéro déchet 6
ici